good morning everybody Welcome to house
Transportation uh before we get started
if I can ask our vice chair Gorski to
lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance
thank you sir
and to get started I'm going to open up
the public hearing being
9 32 on Senate Bill 13 FN relative to
the recovery of search and rescue
expenses
good morning Senator Waters well good
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm Senator David Waters
District 4 and proud to be a member of
the transportation uh Committee in the
Senate but also the Energy natural
resources committee uh which actually
had this bill instead of Transportation
this time around I'm introducing Senate
Bill 13 relative to recovery of search
and rescue expenses at the request of
the fishing game
uh commission to permit the Division of
Motor Vehicles to suspend a revoke a
driver's license when that driver has
failed to make payment to the fish and
game department for the reasonable costs
of a search and rescue for which they're
found to be negligent now let me know
that already an RSA
206 26 BB
so in-state stature we already gave the
authority to fish and game
um
to build a search and rescue
operator you know operation and um then
if the if the payment is not there the
vision game is given under that
provision
uh the suspension of a driver's license
if they're unable to collect the fees so
that's in statute but it was determined
that we needed to do this two things
first you'll see that the bill adds a
language that says now just a side of
notify we have to certify
uh to someone that this request is being
made that's a higher bar which I think
is appropriate and it sets forth a
process you'll see in the bill about
notification about possible appeals
about information provision as requested
by the person who's might be subject to
the suspension so I think that's that's
all good in terms of transparency in
setting a bar because you know this is a
a kind of a last resort for the
Department to need to take this kind of
action to collect those outstanding
costs for search and rescue operation
it also became determined that well yes
we had this Authority for fish and game
but we didn't have the appropriate
Authority in-state statutes so that yeah
then the DMV could take action on that
so that's what you see in the last
paragraph of the bill is to kind of
button that up to say the request can be
made here's the process and then
um there's the authority of DMV to do it
we have Lieutenant Mancini here from
fish and game department
um but let me just talk a little bit
about the the background here I mean I
was on Fish and Game in the house for a
couple terms and we were dealing this
issue
um you know back 15 16 years ago and
we've dealt with it I think in very good
ways in the years since about the
problems of search and rescue operations
these can be extraordinarily expensive
they can involve helicopters they can
put the lives of our conservation
offices and other people at Great risk
especially in the wintertime trying to
find
um you know what may be a negligent uh
negligent hiker and a number of years
ago was getting to the point that this
self-funded department was having to
essentially take money away from other
kinds of you know necessary operations
Department because of this burgeoning
debt over very expensive fishing game
search and rescue operations and so the
consideration was well maybe we need to
start adding some general fund money to
fish and game and we made that decision
to add add some but I think the real
stroke of of Genius here was just do the
hike safe card right that you can go and
that's it you get out just get out of
fear it's not get out of jail but get
out of fee free card and then if you
purchase a hike safe card
um which a lot of people want to do to
contribute to the department and its
operations keep our Trails safe and and
uh and so on you can do that and then if
you are subject to search and rescue
even if you're negligent you're covered
it's your insurance insurance policy and
that's been very successful programs
some other states have done it and
that's that that's a really good good
move but we have folks who do not buy
the hugsafe card
um oftentimes from you know out of state
and uh search and rescue operation is
determined that they are negligent and
let me say that that negligence is a
narrow category because you know people
get into trouble on the trails right
it's not if you slip and you you know
you break an angle or something like
that um but if you're truly negligent
shouldn't be out there or in conditions
um and circumstances where any
reasonable person would think that was
negligence um then the fish and game
department decides you are subject to
this this charge for searching search
and rescue uh rescue cross but then what
do we do if they don't pay
um and you know one alternative is to
try to collect that money
um it's very expensive to try to collect
money from folks uh and it's also
sometimes people just you know you can't
get them and it just it just won't pay
so the one remaining tool we have in our
tool chest is this licensed suspension
um we have reciprocal arrangements with
other states so that if we suspend a
license suspended but for someone who's
an out-of-state license we can we can
have that uh enforced
um and so that's we're doing a variety
of things but it is a kind of a tool of
Last Resort but I I think given our
commitment to the fishing game
um Department
um I I really hope we can support it and
um transportation committee appropriate
well I'm sure look at this very
carefully I'm always a little anxious
about anything that takes away someone's
driving privileges because that's how
you get to work and other things but you
know we have
um some there's a set number I think
about 80 80 I think Colonel Jordan said
about 80 people and maybe tenant Mancini
will will follow up on that just the
numbers we're talking about
um but they need our help so thank you
Mr chairman glad to answer a few
questions but I kind of really would
just like to defer to the lieutenant
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
wow I won't let you know I've got a
couple we're we're in hearings over in
the Senate so oops okay yeah go ahead
representative Jones
uh I just want to know is this strictly
for state land or is this also cover
Federal lands and private lands
and so on
um and so I'll pertain to them all yeah
I mean I I if I'm incorrected but you
know we we um we do search and rescue
wherever wherever somebody needs it
wherever they are yes if they're on a
trail in New Hampshire and they need
search and rescue we're going to go try
the hike safe card
airplanes also yes thank you yeah okay a
couple quick ones if you don't mind
Senator sure um the hook say program how
much money does that generate do you
know
you have those okay I'll defer
um and the other one maybe you'll defer
as well in terms of determining
negligence who does that or do we have a
definition and statute for that
another one okay yeah you're good thank
you thank you Senator thank you I'll see
you in a while
uh next up Cher recognizes Bob Mancini
from New Hampshire Fish and Game
good morning chair Walsh members of the
transportation committee my name is
Lieutenant Bob Mancini and I'm a
lieutenant over at our headquarters I
work directly with Colonel Jordan major
Walsh and Captain Eastman during my
career I've been a member of our search
and rescue team the dive team and I've
also had a canine
so over the course of those years I've
participated in several hundred missions
and the things I'll speak to today are
based on my personal experience and and
just the data that we've derived from
our databases I'm going to try to touch
on a few of the things that Senator
Waters
went over just to offer a little bit of
detail but thank you Senator Waters very
much for for offering all of those those
facts
in 2022 hike safe generated 311 thousand
dollars
currently
right now it's generated about a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars
the SAR fund which which Senator Waters
discussed was created in the 1980s and
basically what it did was a dollar from
boats snow machines and ohrvs was was
essentially put into a pool that has
averaged about 180 000 over the course
of time
um not so much in the very beginning but
uh average over that time it has been
about 180 180 000 some years a little
higher some years a little lower
historically our staff respond to about
180 search and rescue missions per year
during covid that was a little bit of an
inflated but it's historically been
about 180 and in that time the average
cost per year has been about three
hundred thousand dollars some years
higher nearly 400 000 some years a
little lower about a quarter of a
million dollars
with regards to the bills I just I wanna
kind of shine a little light on
we are not sending out a ton of bills so
if we if we're averaging 180 missions
per year in 2022 only eight bills were
sent out
in 2021 17 bills were sent out in 2020
15 bills so when it when we're
determining negligence I think
it is a very narrow focus and we're
trying to be reasonable when applying
whether somebody's negligent or not and
that's based on the field observation so
a lieutenant is The Incident Commander
on these missions and they are going to
make a recommendation to the colonel
whether whether somebody was negligent
in their activity and a billing memo is
sent up and it's included with the
report but our process excuse me
our process in the law enforcement
division is that a member of our staff
identifies the person that's been
involved in this incident and they get
the best address for them they ask them
is this where you get your mail so on
and so forth a report is generated and
then
um
a bill his a bill is sent after it's
been determined that such bill is
necessary a bill is sent phone calls are
made there's there's follow-up with
multiple ways of sending it in the mail
and on the phone and after exhausting
all of the options to collect the funds
that is when we would ask that
somebody's license be suspended after
exhausting multiple phone calls offering
payment plans providing a hearing
even even
reducing the amount of the bill that's
when we would ask that someone's driving
privileges would be suspended so we're
not we're not trying to make this run
rampant and we're not trying to
put anybody in a deficit for their life
to be able to travel to work but there
is a real cost associated with every one
of these missions
and there's a lot of things that are
unforeseen in the future you know a
recent helicopter rescue alone exceeded
eighty thousand dollars
the National Guard
submits a billing waiver to the National
Guard Bureau so the fish and game
department doesn't have to incur that
cost if that ever changes that was one
Mission eighty two thousand dollars so
if we don't have some some teeth in this
this bill that originated in 2015 you
know 206 26 BB was in 2015 and and the
legislative Authority and the intent of
that was to do what we're asking to do
today was that after multiple attempts
to try to get somebody to to pay the DMV
would suspend their driving privileges
that happened back in 2015 it just
during that time
most recently director of Motor Vehicle
bolecki who who had
she's not there now it's marasco but she
requested to us to try to firm this up
and Colonel Jordan over the past year
and a half worked with the Attorney
General's office to firm up this bill
which is what you have in front of you
Senate Bill 13 FN
so I hope I've offered just a little bit
more clarity on all of this and I'm
happy to try to take any questions that
you may have
thank you sir questions from the
committee
representative Fox
thank you Mr chair I may have missed you
may have said this and I may have missed
it but what is the average bill that was
sent out just for one of these years
I'll run through the the cost of each
bill for the eight that happened in
2022. there was one bill for 752 dollars
there was a bill for 206 dollars there
was a bill for 1216 another bill for
169.
a bill for just over
2500 and then another bill for a
thousand so some of these are they're
they're not you know huge money could it
be again when you when you have a
multiple day search that involves a lot
of officers that have been on regular
time and overtime and Equipment have
been equipment's been used it it could
get expensive I'll try to go through
one that happened
in recent
I'm looking at 2020 and 2021 right now
the highest bill that I see sent out
in the past three years was for four
thousand and twenty five dollars
thank you and I'm actually going to
follow up on her question could you
provide the committee wouldn't say those
last three years of these expenses
in the future not today and What's the
total
everything considered average
expense for the year for all the search
and rescues not just the ones that may
get a bill but but in general and the
reason I'm asking these questions is
because we currently have retained House
Bill 650 which is seeking to remove the
latest suspension of licenses for
everything that's not motor vehicle
related so the more importance we can
see with this it might help sure
I I can certainly provide the committee
with with the bills that were within the
last three years I have that that form
here I'd have to make copies
um
with regard to the total cost it has it
has been
total cost for for dive search and
rescue
walkaways Alzheimer's missing children
has been anywhere between 180 and 240
missions per year over the last decade
and the average cost has been between
you know 350
000 coming upwards of four hundred
thousand dollars and those costs have
been offset by the hike safe card which
again last year three hundred and eleven
thousand and then the search and rescue
fund which has the ohrv snow machine and
boat registration so thankfully that
hike safe was it has been working
obviously we can't force anybody to buy
a 25
individual card and we can't force
anybody to buy the 35 family card but
that funding mechanism has been working
and it's it's helping stabilize things
but we have 1.4 million people in the
state of New Hampshire and it's a
beautiful state and the outdoor
recreation community it's only growing
it's not just Hunting Fishing trapping
there's there's lots of people that are
kayaking and boating
um and just out walking and enjoying
enjoying nature so
I think a bill like this is important
for the future because
in the event that you have less people
that actually want to contribute to the
Department
and you have more people that are out
just for their own intrinsic benefit
they don't have a an overarching
you know
they don't they don't necessarily care
about the New Hampshire Fish and Game
department they want to come and
recreate they're from far away
this bill will give us a little bit of
leeway if you will to kind of collect
the funds associated with the search and
rescue missions of our state it's not a
huge financial impact I can think of it
being much more important for not
reducing it for all the other stuff
because we have a lot of people that
don't pay
you know a speeding ticket and we have a
lot of people that don't pay a snow
machine or a hunting or a fishing ticket
and one of the only reasons that they do
end up paying the court is because
their license privileges is going to get
suspended so I
I'm scared about that one for sure
we needed your testimony on 650.
representative sakes I'm okay
okay representative
thank you and thank you lieutenant for
taking my question
um you mentioned that the process is you
find someone negligent and then you know
you send the letter out and then there's
multiple calls and all that can you give
us an idea of from the time that it's
determined that it's negligent
what's the time period that all these
calls are done
over is a couple months is it you know
half a year what is it
it it depends um I know you probably
hate hearing that but some people are
very um very compliant and are
accountable so you send them a bill and
they call you and say I want to take
care of this right away in that regard
the mission happened in February the
report was completed by the end of
February March the billing memo went out
by the end of March it's resolved so I
would say six to eight weeks it could be
resolved if somebody takes that
accountability
we wouldn't we wouldn't be as Hasty if
somebody didn't answer the written
record so now we're calling now we're
trying to do additional research
reaching out to a state do you have an
updated address for this person even
though they supplied us with an address
we're looking at motor vehicle records
to see if there's a different address
somewhere and we're sending it certified
mail to multiple residences sometimes
and trying to do follow-up calls and
calling a person that was associated
with that rescue do you have updated
contact information so that that all of
that could be six months or more
by the time you're doing some follow-up
because these people are from out of
state
um I had one where a gentleman was from
Texas and he was out on the trail he was
a through hiker and he said he never got
any of that stuff and so
it took months to track him down and
ultimately he did comply and he and he
paid some of it but
I would say a minimum of six to eight
weeks and a maximum it could be upwards
of a year and if they want to push the
process and
um
they they want to have a hearing and
then they want to challenge it all the
way up to the superior and Supreme Court
it could be years I've seen that in my
career as well
you mentioned out of Staters what
happens without a Staters do can we
revoke like you mentioned the person
from Texas
um if they didn't pay do we have the
ability would this bill have the ability
to revoke licenses in Texas there's
reciprocity there is reciprocity amongst
driving privileges in the United States
I don't I couldn't speak to every state
that's reciprocal with the state of New
Hampshire but I can
generally there is reciprocity and
especially in the New England states
where those are the folks that are going
to be more likely recreating in our in
our state
yes for the questions
representative good
see thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question uh I was
wondering
um about how many search and rescue
events you have in a year uh and break
that down with how many have had the
hikes safe cards or and some other
provision and you know down to how many
you're having to chase after you know is
that separate the 18 that you mentioned
is that separate from ones who paid
right away when you send them a bill
so breaking down the number of people
that have a hike safe card I I don't
have that compared to the 180
um I can tell you that sometimes the
people that we rescue do have a hike
Safeguard and they're like I have a hike
safe card I don't have it with me but I
I have one can you look it up so they're
they're all excited and then people are
also that have hunting fishing
um
ohrv snow machine they'll they'll also
let you know but
we we wouldn't we have not historically
billed anybody that has any of those
things if they have a hike safe card if
they have a family hike safe if they
have a snow machine registration ohrv
registration boating registration height
Hunting Fishing we we hit we have just
not build them
so if you are a consumptive user for the
New Hampshire Fish and Game department
if you're putting any resource into the
kitty
we have not billed that person
this is this is for the people that that
are
have been negligent and haven't done
anything
from a cost perspective to help bolster
the New Hampshire Fish and Game
department
the consumptive users the people that
are that are paying the salaries and and
doing that
we we have not build them and I'm sorry
if I didn't answer your question
representative all right thank you
what are the questions
I guess deal representative sellers yeah
thank you thank you Mr chair
um I might have missed part of this at
the hike safe car could you explain that
again from one and I just wanted to find
out have you thought about
and and this is you could probably
explain it as you along but is there a
like an insurance card if that is you
know so purchase it and do you give them
maybe a tracking device that's good for
the year or something
so with with regard to the hike safe
card uh in the past in 2022 there was 12
191 hike safe cards that were purchased
of that 7 321 were individuals
4870 were families of that six thousand
one hundred and sixty were residents of
the state and six thousand Thirty One
were non-residents that that number may
surprise you but those that's the
breakdown and and they totaled three
three hundred thousand and ele you know
three hundred eleven thousand dollars
so
it is it is definitely helping as far as
tracking
um or having a tracking device we don't
we don't have that the hike safe Card is
only good for the calendar year so it's
purchased between January 1st and it
expires on December 31st and this the
hike safe card right now is for
um if if for me as a family it would be
it would cover me my wife my four and a
half year old son and my three-year-old
daughter that's who would be covered if
I had stepchildren they would also be
covered and if I was deemed to be a
guardian of the state for another minor
they would be covered but that's who
would be covered under a family plan the
individual plan is self-explanatory
and again
boat ohrv snow machine hunting fishing
license all provide you with the same
the same guarantees if you will and it's
not an insurance card
um there there are
there are agencies not not so much State
agencies but actual insurance companies
that will sell you
a rescue insurance
but we we don't do that
for the questions
and I had one last one and I'll let you
off the hook we're going to get into our
next Hearing in a minute anyway my
question is because it always I always
I'm always uneasy when I hear that one
individual can determine negligence it's
not a judge by the way
um can you just give me quickly an
example of what would-be negligence on
as it's looked at right now and when
it's not sure sure
ah so this one this one might blow your
mind but I you asked for an example so
I'll give you one uh very very
um
wet forecasted
um cold precipitation was going to be
high winds were going to be extremely
high a person that just went out
um that just had a double hip
replacement thought it would be a good
idea to take a 60 pound pack
up onto the Franconia Ridge Trail in
treacherous conditions and ultimately
required a rescue
so
that would be one that is a
I mean I I think
that's that's extreme but I was on it I
I you know I watched officers that I was
hiking with
come real close to being hypothermic and
being you know a casualty themselves so
we we try to educate folks we have a
hike safe program we're in schools we
reach out to the public we have you know
we just had discover wild New Hampshire
day where 8 000 people come and we're
we're really trying to connect people to
life Outdoors that through education so
thankfully that doesn't happen all the
time the the vast majority of them that
wouldn't be negligent is that you know a
family went out and they read the map
wrong they got spun around and they took
a drainage as opposed to coming down a
trail this little drainage meandered off
and they thought it was a trail and they
went down and ended up in a brook
drainage and followed that and they were
they were never on the trail and they
called and panicked and we try to get
them back onto the trail but they say
it's dark and we don't have lights
um and that in that case you know we try
to work with them and most of the time
those people will they'll actually send
a donation they'll they want to take
responsibility
so again I want to want to point out in
circle back that eight eight bills in
2022 7 and 20 17 in 2021 and 15 in 2020.
this is
this is a small number
based on the the 180 average that we
have and really it's two or three people
are pushing this process to where it
would be the suspension per year it's a
very small number most of our people are
good the people that are recreating here
are good people
thank you very much
I have nobody else signed up to speak on
Senate Bill 13 so I'm going to close the
public hearing
a couple of minutes to reset and we'll
get into Senate bill 118.
all right being 1002 we'll open up the
public hearing on Senate Bill 118
requiring children under the age of two
years to be restrained in a motor
vehicle uh chair recognizes the prime
sponsor welcome back Senator Fenton
thank you so much it is it's good to be
home as they say
um thank you Mr chair and Ladies and
Gentlemen of the committee for the
record I am Senator Donovan Fenton I
represent uh Senate District 10. I'm
here today to talk to you about Senate
Bill 118 which would require children
under the age of two to be restrained in
a rear-facing car seat
the American Academy of Pediatrics has
expanded their car seat recommendations
to keep children rear-facing for as long
as possible
they did this because it will help save
lives every month at a child rides we
were facing gives them more time for the
head and neck to fully develop
a rear-facing car seat cradles the
child's entire body it only takes 1 4
inch of a stretch for a child's spinal
cord to rupture using the correct
currency can decrease death or Serious
injury by 70 percent and you'll see an
example later on this bill fills a much
needed Gap in child safety laws here in
New Hampshire
rear-facing car seats are no more
expensive than front-facing there's no
ABS there's absolutely no reason or
extra costs to why you should not have
your child rear-facing for as long as
possible
this bill does not overlap any existing
laws and helps protect our most
vulnerable population it also follows
the manufacturer laws so that if your
child is larger than average it does not
apply
we had a commissioned to study this and
collect data and what we found was that
rear-facing car seats unequivocally are
the better choice not a single group or
individual who testified told us
otherwise
currently there is no language to
protect this group and this bill will do
just that we have some experts speaking
so if you have any questions I urge you
to ask them but I'm always open for
questions thank you guys so much
thank you any questions from the
committee
just one for me yes sir no you said
there was a choice it's a logical choice
to buy rear facing so that means that
you're currently front-facing child
seats they would still accommodate the
younger and smaller there are there are
so we have someone from Chad who deals
with car seat safety so we could
probably answer that but there are
convertible car seats that can be
forward-facing or rear-facing yep
I would know the questions thank you
very much guys let me off easy thank you
so much for having me
thank you
okay next up she recognizes I think it's
James edston uh representing Dartmouth
Health in support of the bill seeking
five minutes
welcome
for the record my name is Jim Heston I
work for Dartmouth Health children's I'm
also the chair for the New Hampshire
Safe Kids Coalition we are in support of
this bill and the reason is children
as you all know have very weak neck
strength the issue becomes that in the
event of a crash their heads are going
to go forward there can be spinal
injuries neck injuries all along the way
what this bill would do is allow
children to ride rear-facing longer
giving that neck strength a chance to
grow it to build
and in the event of a crash we know that
the majority of crashes are from the
front being in that car seat is going to
allow them to write out the initial
major crash forces that are happening
and then um there'll be the the
reciprocal forces applied to them when
they go forward back after that so
that's one of the reasons that we're
very much in support of this the
American Academy of Pediatrics and
um the CDC both recommend that children
write rear facing as long as their seat
will allow them the nice thing about
this bill is that with the two-year
limit in there what we're doing is in
the past they used to say one year with
this what it's allowing is the children
to um write that again be be rear-facing
but we all know that there are two types
of child safety seats one is the
rear-facing only which is one you're
probably familiar with it has the
carrier it goes into a base in the car
those have a limit of depending on the
type of seat anywhere from 22 to 30
pounds
the type of seat that we're talking
about that would accommodate the
children is a convertible seat so it's
structured in such a way that the
children can ride rear-facing and max
out the seat's weight which in a lot of
cases is 40 pounds to 45 pounds and then
it allows the the seat to go forward
facing so when they do Max that out they
can go and um
uh ride forward-facing
um again so the issue becomes with a lot
of parents they want to see their
children and it's a lot easier to see
them when they're writing and that that
forward-facing position but again from a
standpoint of data and everything else
that we have we know that writing the
rear facing is going to be the better
one for them
so
any questions I can answer for you thank
you certain questions from the committee
representative Jones
thank you Mr chairman
um thank you for coming sir um
I just want to add the American Academy
of Pediatrics that's that's a
that's Physicians who are concerned
about their wealth and well-being of
they're not a third party certification
is there like a manufacturer's
third-party certification that tells you
which equipment is safe and which isn't
so the national highway traffic safety
administration does a lot of work with
car seat testing um there are there's
also the Insurance Institute that tests
these car seats out so that they know
what um what kind of Crash forces that
will happen and they they do crash test
some of them
and that that is available
that data's available I don't have it
but I could certainly no I'm not asking
for it no I the public can find it
themselves thank you you're welcome any
other questions from the committee
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question thank you the
um do you know the number of zero to
two-year-olds that are in crashes and
haven't survived or have been a problem
in New Hampshire
I don't have that number available to me
right here
um but we can certainly get that for you
as well
thank you for the questions did you want
to follow up yep follow up thank you
the other question I had was uh the cost
of these car seats I mean we know the
the families have to buy a car seat
anyway but you're talking about a
special car seat a convertible one
um what about the families that really
have uh maybe a very low income you know
how how are they are these car seats
being provided or how do they purchasing
these
okay so the first part of that question
um we can help provide those car seats
for them through grants we have fitting
stations around the state of New
Hampshire
um in in at least um 50 or 60 of those
that can help out parents that need
those the rear-facing seats um the
rear-facing only seat with the with the
carry handle and in the basket
um we don't provide those we do provide
the convertible car seats so that they
can use those much longer and that's the
advantage of the convertible again
you're using it rear facing and
forward-facing
for the questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
uh next up chair recognizes
representative Leon opposed to the bill
is taking three minutes
welcome thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee last year I
participated on the committee to
evaluate basically to evaluate the data
on rear-facing child seats and to figure
out what data we had where the benefits
were and we spoke to a lot of different
experts we actually found that
fortunately this is not much of a
problem in New Hampshire because the
number of crashes with injuries to young
children is very very very very small we
actually don't have any good data on how
many children under two years old are
involved in these crashes and we don't
have any good data on what seats they
are in they are generally broken down in
the zero to four year age range and
several of these children were listed as
being one years old in one of the
reports being in a booster seat which I
don't think is actually even really
physically possible to have a child
under four years under one year old in a
booster seat so there are serious
problems with our data here in New
Hampshire
um beyond that though we had some other
fantastic data we had a gentleman come
in and on zoom and speak to us and
actually we'd all be safer in
rear-facing car seats because the human
body is designed to take impact on the
back as you're laying down as opposed to
on the front but there are a lot of
other factors that also come into play
when you have these car seats they do
take a lot of space up in the car I'm a
mom to three boys and
let me tell you it was really hard
trying to fit a rear-facing car seat
into a sedan with a family of five we
were able to do that with one of those
bucket carriers the ones that now go up
to some of them actually go up to 35
pounds but you also have height limits
in those seats when it came time to put
my youngest son in a rear-facing seat
one of the convertibles it was
physically impossible to get that into
my husband's car without displacing the
front passenger so ins you'd either have
to have that with their knees in the
dashboard which also isn't safe and
you'd have to disable the airbag or
possibly not fit anybody so then when
you have a family that doesn't have a
giant sequoia like I do you end up
making low-income families buy a
different car to fit their family
we're not talking about the price of a
car scene we're talking about having
extra seating capacity to accommodate a
car seat for a certain amount of time
you know we also might be talking about
a family that is reducing the amount of
food that's going to their kids for an
event that has happened an event that is
very very rare
we I believe I can get the numbers for
you but I believe that there were six
children under four who had a
significant injury enough to go to the
hospital not necessarily
life-threatening but a serious injury
obviously in recent events we had a
tragedy with some young children in a
car so we do know that those numbers
have gone up
looking at this bill there's another big
problem
when you look at states where they have
an age limit
everybody's really excited about when
their kid graduates and gets to sit
forward facing he's two years old in one
day let's set him forward facing but
extended rear facing is the safer choice
we should have been be encouraging
parents with data and facts to rear
faces as long as they can with their
kids up to three four even five years
old If the child will tolerate it
because it is safer but when we set set
the limit of two years then we introduce
this idea of well he's reached the
second birthday so we're going to turn
him around and you actually end up
reducing that safety
basically it's an education issue this
doesn't not all education issues not all
recommendations need to be law and this
law would end up hurting some of our
lower income families and this law
really is is not necessary here in New
Hampshire we have a vet we have a safe
culture of safety we have a higher we
have very high seat belt usage despite
not having a law for adults and we have
a lot of families that know that rear
facing is the way to go we just don't
need to criminalize the behavior of
turning them around sooner if that's
what the family needs in order to fit
all their family in the car or because
they needed to be because they had some
other necessary need
so with that I'll take any questions and
I can provide the car seat committee
report to you an email format later
that would be great and I do have one
question you touched on in terms of
Education
how much of that if any of that is
provided now
in terms of the benefits of a particular
type of seat
there is a lot of information out there
a lot of parents seek out people like
the car seat lady and find that
information
the the pediatricians have that
information when you're going to
parenting classes they have that
information they discuss it with you in
your prenatal visits to make sure that
you have a car seat that is appropriate
and there's a lot of Education that does
happen already and there's also Flyers
about the car seat installation events
as well
thank you for the questions from the
committee representative Jones
thank you um
more comment than a question we'd only
take questions here representative it's
it's a question okay okay
uh
I is it true so now it's a question
um that you shouldn't be using car seats
that that you've bought used or bought
from a consignment store because they
may have been an accident and they may
have meet their stress limit already is
that correct
um yes you should never use a car seat
whose history you don't know and if
you're involved in an accident at any
speed you are supposed to replace that
car seat car insurance will replace a
car seat for any vehicle that's in an
accident if it's been installed at the
time of the accident
for the questions
see you then thank you very much I do
have one on the certification by the
ntsa about the car seats and the safety
as far as that safety all any car seat
that's on the market and is available
meets minimum safety standards and when
you end up looking at the data ratings
they're all very very close together so
most of them hold within a very solid
safety standard
thank you and you did say you can you
can provide us with the report yes I
will forward that I had that from Brad
Greenland one of the assistants so I'll
forward that now
okay next up share recognizes Dan
Goodman representing the AAA in support
of the bill looking for three minutes
welcome
I'm sorry about that uh for the record
my name is Dan Goodman and I represent
AAA of Northern New England
um and I just wanted to clarify a point
that I heard earlier this bill would not
require any parent to purchase a new car
seat
um when you when you have a when let's
say you have a newborn
um the nurse at the hospital or someone
at the hospital looks at that car seat
before you leave with your newborn they
would not let you leave in a
forward-facing car seat so what this
bill would just have you keep your child
in that existing car seat that you
already own
up until two years older or until you
reach the higher weight limits of the
car seat
just a quick clarification that's the
way at least I I see it and
I just want to quickly go over a couple
of the studies that
um as has been mentioned there was a
study report completed in 2022 and a
couple of studies that uh that they they
looked at that really show that
staying in a rear-facing car seat is the
best thing to do for our children in
2007 the University of Virginia study
found that children were 75 percent
likely to suffer severe or fatal
injuries in a crash if they are facing
in the rear
in 2017 restraint use saved the lives of
325 children each four years and younger
a 2013 Nitza analysis found that correct
child seat safety usage was linked with
a fatality reduction of 57 percent among
children one to three years old there's
also a belief that
parents are properly restraining their
children in AAA study in 2021 found that
52 to 84 percent of car seats that was
inspected by child passenger safety
technicians around the country were
improv or installed incorrectly with the
number one reason for the installation
incorrect was the wrong car seat for
instance putting a forward-facing
putting a child in the forward-facing
car seat too early
a 2018 Ohio State University Medical
Center study looked at rear-facing car
seats and rear impact crashes rear
impact crashes they found that
rear-facing seats are able to support
the child's head neck and Spine and keep
those vulnerable body regions well
protected these reasons are especially
vulnerable in newborns younger children
whose spine and vertebrae haven't fused
and fully developed
um I think uh yeah you know with our
existing law seven to fifty seven years
old or 57 pounds this will provide this
bill would provide the education that
parents I think really need as has been
mentioned in many of the bills here
Traffic Safety bills it's a three-legged
stool education enforcement engineering
they have designed the car seats designs
have improved over the years so we've
engineering there's CPS technicians and
the Department of Safety Office of
Highway Safety providing a lot of
Education throughout the state but it's
lacking is that enforcement piece and
this bill will close that Loop and with
that thank you very much
thank you I do have one question to
clarify something I thought I heard you
say
did you say hospitals would hold
children hostage until they have a
rear-facing child seat installed in the
car
thank you for that question chairman
they they it it sometimes feels like
they heldu host they do not hold you
hostage but they would when when they I
actually don't know exactly what they
would do but I'm my understanding is
they they would not
when when I first with my first child
who's four now they were installed
incorrectly and they they reinstalled it
um put them properly fast and and I was
told that if I had the wrong car seat
they would help me get a better car seat
if that helps answer your question
no but that's okay and further questions
from the committee
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair
the uh I'm trying to figure out how many
parents this may affect that don't do
this now you know I I mean are we
especially in New Hampshire I mean is it
one two fifty five hundred I mean it
just seems like the number is so tiny
I'm not sure this is necessary do you
have any data or anything on that
thank you for the question I I don't
have any data I'm not sure if the CPS
technicians around the state compile
data on incorrect car seats what they
what they see it and and a lot of that
data that we're seeing from the CPS tax
which is when we see like I stated 52 to
84 percent of car seats are installed
incorrectly that's only really from a
small percentage of parents or
grandparents who are bringing their cars
into these check stations at fire
stations and police departments
um so so unfortunately I don't have that
data
the questions from the committee
seeing them thank you very much thank
you I have nobody else signed up to
speak on Senate Bill 118 so I'm going to
close the public hearing
um next one is scheduled for 10 30. so
we have a few minutes to regroup thank
you
okay being 10 32. I'm open up the public
hearing on Senate Bill 187 relative to
driver's licenses for certain Visa
holders Prime sponsor is not available
so representative Sykes has been kind
enough to introduce the bill
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the transportation committee for the
record I am representative George Sykes
Grafton 13 uh Ward 2 and Lebanon New
Hampshire
um
so I I want to call to your attention
the fact that and here he is you want to
introduce your bill Senator yeah
I thought at 10 30 I'm sorry I'm sorry
well we he's
there we go
despite what he said here's the Bill
thank you Mr chairman and uh my
apologies for being a couple minutes
late I'm Senator David Waters Richard
Ford introduced
um Senate Bill 187 relative to the
driver's licenses for certain Visa
holders now I suppose it's deja vu that
I'm here again before you second time
the day and it's also maybe a little bit
of Daisy review for some of you on this
issue and this bill because um the
committee I thank them for their good
work uh last year on a version of this
we didn't quite get there but having
benefited from what this committee
suggested there were issues that need to
be addressed we worked over it on this
uh and I'm very grateful to director
rasho and Jeff oberdanka who have kind
of I think come up with some pretty good
language
um that protects New Hampshire's
interests and yet helps our Farmers out
with this issue of the h2a Visa Visa so
um let me just describe a little bit why
um this is helpful uh for us and can
solve some problems for the state
um there's h2a workers are agricultural
workers who come under a special Visa to
work on our our Farms you know about
we've got about 240 to 250 Farms not all
of them need this labor but several of
the larger operations do as we will as
we will hear and um these folks have
been coming for decades and decades and
a lot of times a particular Farm there's
a relationship with a group of workers
they come up these visas are good for a
10-month stay which is you know harvest
season planning and harvest season plus
and they're going to need to be able to
be on on the roads now
um it has been in others in others the
states around us that there's a
recognition of certain kinds of uh
international driver's license or
driver's licenses for other countries
and because we don't have that
explicitly in State Statute a couple of
things are are happening they're here
for the 60 days and it kicks in
um uh under
263.35 that they're supposed to get a
state license if they're here for more
than 60 days well they don't want that
and it's kind of because it'd be kind of
inappropriate for them they got their
license they're not they're not wanting
to be residents of New Hampshire
but since we don't recognize these other
forms of Licensing then they're kind of
stuck the second thing is that the feds
have been coming in in the Department of
Labor and they've been wanting to find
these Farms
because they the state doesn't have this
program
um and this is a you know a problem for
our our farmers and again all the states
around us they do something like this
and there's no issues about the
Department of Labor coming in and trying
to I think harass our Farmers although I
know I shouldn't use that word but um
that's that that's is the way it seems
to me
um so the bottom line here is how do we
enable these particular Visa holders to
come and do the agriculture work and be
able to operate their farm equipment or
to drive
um on a valid license from another
jurisdiction while they are are here
while we make sure that we protect our
roads and New Hampshire citizens by
knowing that these drivers have good
safety records
and have a license that ensures that
they've had at least as rigorous a
training and requirements for getting
that license as we'd have for New
Hampshire resident
so that's the background
um to this and uh again thanks to
um the
division on the language that we come up
here about reciprocity agreements for
h2a workers now we have existing
reciprocity Arrangements on licensings
with uh with some Nations we're working
on one with kind of we passed some
legislation did something like this for
Taiwan in terms of reciprocity
agreements so we do we do these kinds of
things and this is a a particular way to
address these kinds of of workers
um
so
they cannot operate a motor vehicle in
New Hampshire unless starting lines five
and six
and here are the criteria that we came
up with he or she holds the valid
driver's license or permit to operate a
motor vehicle issued by another Juris
U.S jurisdiction so that could be
another state where they have been
working and we recognize licenses issued
by other other states
or starting on line nine he or she holds
a valid driver's license or permit
to operate a motor vehicle from a
jurisdiction outside the United States
18 lawfully present in the country under
this Visa program
is present for less than a year well
that's the 10 months of the program I
mean you can get an h2a visa for up to
three years but it's a 10 it's it
basically it's a 10 month Visa that
they're operating under
um so I've been here less than a year
he or she possesses an international
driver permit
if their home country license is not in
English
so
that's important if an officer pulls
someone over
and wants to determine if it's a valid
license they need to be able to have
some days in English and if their home
country license is not then the
international driver's permit which is
what something they can get will be
um now let me just mention a little more
in the background on this and the work
that was uh done with these foreign
jurisdictions a lot of these workers are
from Jamaica they have long provided
agricultural workers to the Northeast
and as I said there are some Decades of
relationships with these workers who
come up to the same farms and we had a
consular official from Jamaica come up
to the Senate hearing who very
thoroughly described to us the licensing
requirements which are actually stricter
than New Hampshire ones and also the
assurance that we have that if someone
has committed a violation down there
then we're going to know about it
and if somebody commits a violation up
up here that then they're going to be
subject to Driver's loss in their home
Home Country so that was very helpful to
hear but it's not just Jamaica we've had
some from South Africa we've had some
from Mexico uh sprinkling from other
countries countries potentially
um so that's the kind of Workforce that
we're we're dealing with
um this is something the Farm Bureau
um
supports uh we've had a lot you know the
farmers come down to support and um I
hope Mr chairman members of the
committee that you see how we benefited
from your deliberations last time and
came up with a bill that addresses the
questions that you raise so uh thank you
and I I know um I'm really grateful that
director Racha is here
um who can you know talk a lot of the
ins and outs about how we do reciprocity
and how this will work for
for for the division so thank you
yeah thank you for that Senator I was
going to mention to the committee we do
have uh director marasco signed up to
speak so in terms of how the law
actually functions right now questions
uh about those would be best served by
him that being said any questions for
Senator Waters
seeing
representative Hill yeah thank you Mr
chairman thank you good morning Senator
good morning
um
you you are anticipating with this
legislation that there would be a formal
agreement between New Hampshire and
their home state so Jamaica and Mexico
and the other countries that you
mentioned yeah is that I don't see that
spelled out in the legislation so that's
what I was thanks for that question
um you know
there is an option there
I mean this what's nice about this bill
is that it takes care of a variety of
jurisdictions
and we don't want to leave our Farmers
hanging if it just happens that we have
a that there's a jurisdiction with which
we have not gone through the you know
kind of lengthy process of working
through reciprocity but as we're doing
with Taiwan right now we can do that
um we you know we can do that process
process of one one country
um I think though for the particular
purpose of h2a visas which are this
particular
form a Visa for agricultural workers
that this approach is probably much more
efficient
and a little more comprehensive than the
process of doing a reciprocity agreement
with every single country from which
someone might arrive and the reciprocity
agreement is going to probably cover a
lot more than just these these Visas so
I think this is a good way to go but
that your your question you know you can
I think ask director Morocco because
we've had some conversation about that
too
mm-hmm
any other questions
we have one last one yeah line seven it
brings up a question
uh he or she all developed license to
permit operated motor vehicle issued by
another U.S jurisdiction so question is
is New Hampshire the only state that
does not have jurisdiction or recognize
Jamaican licenses or are there others
thank you
um my understanding from working over
this last couple years is that
we are doing one of our surrounding
states
that doesn't take care of this
so you know a worker who's picking
apples or other something up in Maine
and may have a you know under main has
gotten a recognition
um might come over to work in New
Hampshire
so but but we're the only state that
doesn't you know take care of this
because it's not just the workers right
it's the farmers who are getting the
Department of Labor coming in and
finding them some substantial amounts
because we don't have this in statute
so that's the other part of this that
this will take care of yeah
um
I'll leave that one a little because it
looks like a U.S jurisdiction would be a
state yeah um
did you and your research on this this
is something I did not look into really
get into the weeds where the Department
of Labor is even going into this mode
you mentioned harassment but is there
more to it than that I think we'll hear
from the farmer who's been affected okay
thank you any other questions
seeing that thank you sir thank you
okay
uh next up chair recognizes
representative Ming representing Hollis
Hillsborough 35 in support of the bill
looking for a couple of minutes
thank you Mr chair and transportation
committee members my name is Ben Bing
I'm a state representative for the town
of Hollis I'm speaking today in support
of SB 187
I'm here both at the request of Trevor
Hardy of the Brookdale Fruit Farm who is
one of my constituents and as a resident
of the farming community that is Hollis
many of our Farms have employed
temporary agricultural workers from
Jamaica
with Brookdale itself employing dozens
under the federal h2a program
they've done so for nearly four decades
and over that period of time complaints
are violations involving h2a workers
driving work vehicles and Hollis have
been minimal if not completely
non-existent
farming is important to Hollis because
agriculture has an outsized impact on
the way it feels to live there
as a member of my Town's planning board
I get to hear what people care about the
most
as it relates to how land is used
and it's usually one of two things the
impact on schools or the effect on Rural
character
although rural character has a very
specific definition in our zoning code
most people use it to express that they
like living in a small tight-knit
community
connected to Agriculture and nature
multi-generational families like the
Hardys could tell you that much has
changed in Hollis since they first set
down their Roots but we still have easy
access to Fresh Foods and veg and
vegetables and they're still Scenic Wide
Open Fields all thanks to our local
farms
the success of our Farms drives what it
means for many of our residents to enjoy
living in our community
our Farms are that important therefore
our Farms seasonal workers are that
important they're a part of our
community
which is why I'm here in support of SB
187 and why I ask that you please
support a motion of ought to pass
thank you thank you any questions from
the committee
see you then thanks again thank you
um
next up the chair recognizes Stephen
wooden
representing himself in support of the
bill looking for three minutes
welcome
there we go uh thank you very much for
the opportunity to speak to this I am
Stephen wood I uh with my family own and
operate poverty land Orchards and
Farnham Hills ciders in Lebanon and I've
been working at the same Farm since 1965
for my sins we've been employing
Jamaican uh folks through the h2a
program for for over 30 years
um and like I think all of my colleagues
in New Hampshire I was until 19 I mean
2021 unaware of the existence of the law
that this this bill addresses
um and
we have a one gentleman who's got a
valid Jamaican license and also has an
international driver's permit which
would the need for which would be
obviated by this by this bill
um but then a couple of others who just
have Jamaican licenses they've never
been stopped by the police their
driver's record in that entire time is a
hundred percent clean the only thing I
ever
heard from the police was that the chief
of the Plainfield Police called when uh
one of my gentlemen ran the crew fan
into a deer and he called to say please
do not blame this person for this
accident he did a brilliant job trying
to avoid it the police waved to our guys
fortunately I don't think the police
were aware of this law either I became
aware of it uh kind of grimly in 2021
when we got a U.S Department of Labor uh
audit which are irregular and they're um
sort of like
um tidal waves with tidal waves with an
attitude
um but uh we and for failure to comply
fully with state law we were filed find
1250 because our Jamaican gentleman only
had Jamaican licenses and or
International permits that's what I
learned that there was even a law on the
books the one that this
this law thank goodness addresses
um our Farms are spread around
we need to be able to get workers from
one place to another
not all of the Jamaican gentlemen who
work for us drive the ones with licenses
and some of them don't really want to
drive anywhere you know I mean even if
they have licenses but we need them to
be able to drive we've got we've got
Farm farms in Lebanon and farm in
Plainfield
um
last year we tried very hard to get
to get one of them a New Hampshire
license when this bill failed last year
and uh we were
let's see that we were required at the
last minute to come up with a driving
record for for the DMV and I was it it
took us six weeks to get the driving
record from Jamaica so I guess we were
civil disobedience last year but but
this is an important bill and IT
addresses what I hope is just something
resembling an oversight in current law
my record uh the record of our farm
Jamaican drivers Is Not Unusual
um that is to say I'm not aware of any
moving violations at any of my
colleagues forums ever with Jamaican
licensed drivers meanwhile New Hampshire
is unusual in the surrounding states we
are the only one that has this
requirement
so this bill which I hope you will
support
um will bring us into consistency with
our colleagues elsewhere around around
here and uh if we need to I guess we'll
get our gentleman New Hampshire driver's
licenses but I for the life of me can't
understand why that should be necessary
my New Hampshire license has never been
challenged in any country I've ever been
to in the world including a lot of them
that don't speak English
rented cars driven gotten pulled over
for moving violations and not allowed to
continue on my way so I think we should
be show Jamaica the same courtesy that
we are ourselves shunned by other
countries thank you thank you sir
questions from the committee
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman
Mr wood how are you fine thank you sir
how are you I'm well
um one piece that I was wanted a little
Clarity on you made a big effort to get
a driver's record for your employee from
Jamaica and you pointed out that it took
you pointed out the time that it took
but I didn't hear you mention the cost
for you as a phone well thank you thank
you generous question
um you cost a few hundred dollars in the
end because we we were required to send
the all the paperwork over land not by
email
to the Jamaican private agency which
itself charged they charged a couple
hundred bucks
they wanted to set express mail and it
got it got to Miami the next day but it
took four weeks to get to the hands of
the people in Jamaica
um and then there were there were some
other costs associated but it was
several hundred dollars to to fail now
the thing is in truth that was we were
trying to do a last minute job so if I
knew this year what I did not know last
year which is that they had to have a
driver's license but also that they
needed to get their driving record then
I would get a hold of the gentleman
before they come here and say please
bring your driving record when it was
ironic because when the men's driving
record arrived it was that there was it
was spotless forever he'd never had a
moving violation in Jamaica either but
uh yeah it was just another little
another couple of bucks it's like a tip
on the on the dot I mean a DOL thing
thank you sir for the question any other
questions
just one I want to confirm
um you said the the Department of Labor
charged you or fined you 1250 in 2021
2021 sir thank you we talked it down a
little bit I can't remember what we
wound up paying but the original fine
was it's the timing of everything that's
interesting too yeah so uh with no other
questions thank you very much
representative Rich oh just wondering
how expensive it is is it to get an
international driver driving permit
that is mentioned on here is that I
don't think it costs uh anything in
Jamaica I'm sure yeah I don't they they
this this guy just
has it he's always gotten it nobody's
ever required that he has it haven't he
just but I I don't think he'd be doing
it if it cost him a lot of money
he's never mentioned it right that could
be a question for the director and
representative system so seeing all the
questions thank you very much sir thank
you for the rpu to speak and for your
service folks
uh next up chair recognizes Pooh Sprague
representing himself he's a farmer in
support of the bill looking for
hopefully less than five minutes
thank you for the opportunity to testify
um I'll say at the beginning I'm hearing
impaired so we get the questions Point
can I just continue to repeat can I get
you to repeat your name please for our
Clerk
I'm sorry can I get you to repeat your
name for a clerk please
that would be a great group yeah if you
have questions
maybe this is too far away can I just
have you state your name for a clerk
please do you want your name and where
you oh I'm sorry I'm sorry my name's
Pooh Sprague I'm from Plainfield New
Hampshire an interest of brevity I'll
just read the statement to start with
and say for common at the end
our family is owned and operated
Edgewater Farm in Plainfield New
Hampshire since 1974. Edgewater Farm
produces vegetables small fruit
ornamentals in addition to our family
members and local workers we have hide
h2a Jamaican workers for 28 years and
one of the guys that's been with us
started 28 years ago with us and he
worked on another Upper Valley Farm
prior to that
our farm fuels as well as our housing
whether it's seven Jamaican h2a guys
Farmers from whom we contract through
the state and federal government are
spread out between Cornish and
Plainfield as are our fields we rely on
the Jamaican workers who hold valid
international driver's license licenses
to be able to drive on the New Hampshire
roads to these fields and their housing
we need these workers to be allowed to
drive our vehicle so that we can
continue to run our farm business the
way we do I urgently hope that you pass
Senate Bill 187 as presented thank you
for your attention I don't think there's
any new news here in that letter to you
folks
um I would certainly take the measure of
the few farmers
in the room today as not an indication
the importance of spill to all of us
um
we started out 50 years ago an ad in the
paper would get you high school kids
and we can get plenty of people in our
farm to do retail and work in the
greenhouses for small for you know 15 20
hours a week and
quite honestly our we have an aged
Workforce most these people are retired
but we can't get anybody
anybody
to even interview for stoop labor
and that's what we do strawberries Apple
we don't do apples but strawberries
raspberries blueberries squash carrots
small hands and knees labor can't get
can't get College because you can't get
high school kids you need these guys
and so the bottom line is
it's quite a it's quite a you go through
a lot of Hoops to get them here from
Jamaica in the very first place it's not
a simple process I don't call up or I
don't call up Jasper and say Hey you
know call Roy and Garnet and why don't
you guys come up next week it's a
long-involved process with the
Department of Labor uh to get these guys
up at some expense they're not cheap
labor either as you may well know
so this is
this additional New Hampshire license is
another added burden it's hard
these people come up they take one day
off in there we're all worth they're all
working on a farm
so if you can relieve this burden from
from us or prevent it from going out for
that it would really be a great help to
the farming community and I thank you
for your time
thank you very much sir any questions
from the committee
See England thank you again thank you uh
next up chair recognizes Mike Willett a
meadowlack ATV Club in support of the
bill looking for a couple of minutes
wrongdo
thank you
my mistake you did have it on the card
right you just got I was put in the
wrong pile
um let me make sure of this one
Wallace titcome is that for 188 or or
this bill
next bill okay
chair recognizes Robert Johnson New
Hampshire Farm Bureau in support of the
bill
looking for a few minutes
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau as a federation's policy director
in we are in strong support of Senate
Bill 187 a bill enabling h2a Visa
workers employed and living in new on
New Hampshire Farms to driving New
Hampshire on their home country license
Senator Waters initially filed
this legislation last session Senate
Bill 308 as many of you aware at the
request of Farm Bureau
reason we approached Senator watt is
that he served on the 2019 commission to
study the licensing of drivers from
foreign countries and we this was a
request made of him just at the filing
deadline representative Sykes chaired
that Commission
and as you're aware Mr chair this
committee has recommended this Senate
Bill 308 for future legislation
the the h2a agricultural guesswork
program is a temporary Visa program
enabling Farms to hire seasonal
agricultural workers for a period of up
to one year
before they must return home
most of the workers are here four to
eight months sometimes up to 10.
in his was previously said it is an
expensive program
the these farmers are required to pay by
federal law and adverse effect wage rate
in New Hampshire it is set at 16.95 an
hour currently they pay to transport
them to New Hampshire and they pay to
house them
and the reason they do this as was
previously said these are professional
Farm Workers that they cannot get here
these these people are vetted by three
federal agencies in one form or another
Homeland Security
citizenship and immigration the state
department
as far as numbers go in New Hampshire
we're talking about
upwards of 50 farms and now utilizing at
least one h2a worker
over 300 employees Statewide total
as was also said previously a majority
of these workers in New Hampshire are
Jamaican that's different from much of
the rest of the country where of the
total h2a worker pool in this country is
is 97 98 Spanish or Mexican
in New Hampshire where three quarters
Jamaican
we do have some as was also previously
said there are that are Spanish Mexican
with South Africa for example we have I
know in kowas county that some of the
Christmas tree Growers utilize South
African workers
and as again as in in a also want to
point out that
this isn't an issue for the Mexican
workers because of our free trade
agreement that we have with that country
that's why it's kind of this is kind of
a niche with the the Mexican with the
Jamaican South African and other
countries and again I want to stress
these are professional workers these
these gentlemen these Farmers have
long-term relationships with these these
folks and I can tell you what some of
them they go down to Jamaican vacation
with them the many of these workers have
come up here for years the same workers
year after year and when they're done
they they have some their friends or
they have their children that are
working for them
the bill removes an unnecessary burden
on New Hampshire Farm businesses that
has only experienced here in New
Hampshire
and our border states Maine
Massachusetts and Vermont individuals
are permitted to drive on their foreign
issue license for up to one year so just
think about this now
issue workers are coming into Maine
Vermont in Massachusetts and they are
driving into New Hampshire and back
and they're fine
we have people here working on New
Hampshire Farms who cannot drive in the
state they're working in and where would
it be a benefit to our Growers is for
the most part is when these workers are
traveling from field to field these guys
aren't going out and vacationing and
looking at the sites they're working as
16 hours a day so they can pay to send
money back to their families
they're here to work
you know as I said in New Hampshire to
be clear criminal law requires anyone in
the state Beyond 60 days and wishing to
drive hold a valid New Hampshire's
license uh uh or license from another
jurisdiction jurisdiction recognized by
the state
this is also not an issue for h2a
Employers in the other New England
states it's not an issue in New York
it's not an issue in New Jersey it's not
an issue from Pennsylvania again it's
only here in New Hampshire
this this is a a
removing a burden on New Hampshire
businesses these happen to be Farm
businesses
was alluded to early as a catalyst for
the bill comes from an incident an
incident we've had on two New Hampshire
farms uh where again they will find by
the Department of Labor and it was again
it was a paper audit it was the final
was the the conducting an audit it
wasn't where these workers were driving
and then and then nabbed by police it
was just a paper audit with the truth of
it is the Auditors said to the workers
will you have you been driving those
vehicles and they said yes because these
guys told them to be honest
and they and they were which is what the
way it should be
again and in the interest of time I we
we urge you to we we've been at this for
four years now uh to uh uh recommend
this legislation is ought to pass and
and I'd be happy to try to answer any
any questions other than I will try to
answer the question that was asked
earlier regarding the cost of an
international driving permit it's issued
by the the sending Nation so if it's a
Jamaican workby Jamaica and if I
remember it was it was either 25 or 40
dollars not
thank you Mr chair
thank you sir questions from the
committee representative sellers thank
you Mr chair
so you just stated that it's taken up to
fully years for this legislation to
hopefully at one day ought to pass is
that what you're saying we have been
working at on it for four years
is what I'm saying it was introduced
initially at Senate Bill 308
and then now
it's but we're on our side of it it's
been four years we have met numerous
times with the with motor vehicle we
attempted to try to solve it with uh as
Mr wood explained earlier and it was
costly in a time he didn't talk about
that time it cost him
to do all this or the day that he had to
pay his worker to try to he would have
to try his work and to go get his
license
further questions from the committee
representative Hill maybe Mr chair I do
have handouts uh for the committee and
one I do want to point to you with some
uh a written letter from the Jamaican
consulate that answered some questions
that this committee had previously and
that the Senate committees have had but
I'll get those too yes anything you've
got that will be helpful thank you by
all means representative Hill thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um did I understand you correctly in
saying that in New Hampshire we're
currently 75 percent Jamaican and 25
percent
um Spanish or or Mexican
approximately yes you'll see in one of
the handouts that the Jamaican consulate
estimates that they that uh Jamaicans on
40 approximately 40 or so farms and 240
workers I think it says I I think in the
state we're probably in the mid 300s and
we're we're approaching 50 is probably
excuse me yeah approaching 50 so let's
High 40s okay what I'm trying to clarify
is the
um I think I heard you say that the Free
Trade Agreement covers those that are
here that come from Mexico or I'm sorry
if I wasn't clear it covers the driver's
licensing piece
they the the reciprocity in the
licensing so they don't need a a New
Hampshire license we recognize their
Mexican license or other or uh yeah
Mexican license in state and and they uh
follow-ups
um and they're they're recognizing that
license without having any agreement
with that other company uh country other
than the Free Trade Agreement that's my
understanding correct okay thank you
very much that's with Canada because of
the three donation agreement yes
right yeah
yeah any other questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
director marasco and Mike Mercier come
on down
representing the DMV informational
testimony
foreign
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you so much for having us this
morning my name is John marasco I'm the
director of The Division of Motor
Vehicles and I'm here today with Michael
Mercier who is the administrator
overseeing the driver Licensing Bureau
within the agency and assistant
supervisor Ray Fernandez who is seated
here as well and uh Ray was kind enough
to come over Ray has 17 to 18 years of
experience on regarding non-us
transactions at the DMV which are more
complex and deal with different forms of
identification so Ray is here should you
have any additional questions in that
area
um I'd like to start off by saying that
at the DMV and I think Statewide we all
care about the farming Community we want
the farming industry to do well and the
DMV is always focused on getting to yes
and trying to find those areas where we
can partner with industry and other
stakeholders to um to make sure that
we're doing the best that we can that
we're not an obstacle and that we we're
a facilitator in areas where we can be
um
we do have a regular community outreach
meetings once a month some members of
the committee here attend those meetings
and we make changes when there are
opportunities to make changes to rule to
law to internal practice we do that we
do it because it's the right thing to do
and there might be something that's
changed over the years that we need to
take a look at and so that's always
going to be our commitment not just to
the farming industry but every industry
um
so that being said at the end of last
session the bill that's been spoken
about I believe SB 308 that was
referenced by Rob Johnson
we we recognize okay you have a lot of
workers that are coming in from Jamaica
it's the first time that this issue has
been highlighted that I became aware of
it and so we wanted to figure out what
can we do to help try to find a way to
help so
um what we did first was we actually met
with Senator waters on that bill
um took a look at it and actually with
representative Walsh and I believe
representative hill we actually got
together with Senator Waters uh some
supervisors from the DMV and we took a
look at the language from that bill uh
from that last session
um that being said I listened to
testimony from Senator Waters um you
know as far as crafting the bill and I
did have to pull out my phone and I
wanted to go back and look at my email
and I did find an email here that is
back from April 21st of last year and it
actually is from Senator Waters and it
is to uh chairman Walsh and to me and it
has an amendment attached to it SB 308
Amendment 421-22
and the email says Dear Tom and John
here is the amendment with the revision
to 263 uh 35 that John and staff
developed and the revision to the
current bill language we developed at
the meeting I think there is much
improvement uh this is a much improved
Bill and I'm glad that we were able to
include the needed change in
263.35 Tom can send it to OLS unless
there are any further thoughts David so
I I opened up what that amendment was
because this whole conversation going
back to the last session was really
focused on reciprocity you know I mean I
I've been at the DMV a little bit over a
year you know there are there's rsas
such as 263 39a license for aliens
temporarily residing in New Hampshire
that governs how Visa holders are able
to get a license here in New Hampshire
and but there are exceptions to that and
the exception would be you could enter
into a reciprocal agreement with the
country and so we're actually before I
came into this position there's one
that's already started down that track
with Taiwan and I met with the
representatives from Taiwan and I'm
working with Department of Safety legal
on that recipe reciprocity agreement so
the focus for Jamaica was always
reciprocity because actually at that
meeting that representative Walsh and
Hill and Senator Waters and myself and
Jeff hoberdank and Kelly bruniak were at
I actually pulled it up on my phone to
look at what are the licensing standards
in Jamaica
and um what I was pleasantly surprised
by was that they appear to be much more
stringent than they are here in New
Hampshire 21 years of age uh medical
checkup
um more a more robust uh driving portion
of the exam so when you look at
something like that I mean certainly the
reciprocity agreement is something you
can look at and say you know I think we
could make this work you know we could
take a look at how to transfer records
back and forth
um you know how to surrender a license
back and forth and try to get the yes on
this issue but going back to that
attachment that Senator Waters had sent
to us and this is for section 2 6335 it
says in here or a country that has
current driver reciprocity a current
driver reciprocity agreement with the
Department of Safety and then it goes
down to say uh in a different section
from a foreign jurisdiction that has a
reciprocal agreement with the state of
New Hampshire
um so I just wanted to give you that
background because that was always the
Focus that was always the focus the
focus was trying to help the Jamaican
workers that are coming to New Hampshire
which I learned today are 75 percent of
the guest workers coming in and helping
the farming industry that was always the
focus but the reciprocity agreement was
seen as the vehicle to get that over the
finish line and um
and so
um what did we do after the last session
we had that meeting we worked on some
language regarding a reciprocity
agreement we also went and met with the
farming Community Rob was kind enough to
have us over to one of his regular
meetings over on Route 106. we went
there we talked to people we're invested
in trying to help where we can the other
thing is um supervisor Jeff oberdank
from the DMV had worked along with
supervisor Kelly bruniak to set up
opportunities where we could bring DMV
services closer to where these Farms are
because that was one of the things we
heard was that the transportation taking
the workers off the farm for the day to
go to Concord was a heavy lift and it
cost a full day's worth of work so what
do we do there well we tried to
establish transactions in Nashua which
was an area that was requested as well
as Newport
um you know and it's no fault of anybody
but supervisor over dank told me after
we tried to establish these
opportunities for people to come in and
do that work closer to the Farms nobody
came in
that being said I have good news and the
good news is that in the fall we should
be receiving a DMV mobile vehicle um
sorry been ordered and with that we can
go closer to a lot of different
constituents around the state and do DMV
transactions right out of that vehicle
is that something that and we talked
about it at the end of last session that
we would put front and center for the
farming Community the answer is we would
I also want to talk a little bit about
my Senate testimony on this current bill
um you know it was uh I've received this
document this morning and I just want to
I want to be clear with the committee we
did offer informational testimony before
the senate committee before it got to
this point
um on this bill and you know it was
mentioned at one point that um you know
that I supported this bill and I wanted
I wanted the actual notes from that
testimony this testimony would have been
before the Senate Transportation
committee back on
January 31st of this year but it should
be noted that the first bullet under
director marasco director at New
Hampshire DMV first bullet says director
marasco said he opposed the bill on
technical terms however uh now that
there is a point of contact for Jamaica
who was there that day that I offered
the testimony and I had not met before
there can be discussions for license
reciprocity
which we were absolutely thrilled about
and that's always been the focus and now
we have a point of contact and we want
to help the Jamaican workers in the
farming industry here in New Hampshire
and that's going to be our commitment
going forward that being said this
current bill that you have before you
um
some issues that we've identified with
Bill and by the way I did speak with
Senator Waters about this I called him
last night he knows what uh you know
what I'm testifying to in these areas
um it does Define different
um statuses if you will of Visa holders
so if you're a Visa holder coming here
to do contract work you still have to be
beholden to RSA 263 39a and go through
the DMV and get a New Hampshire license
if you're an international student and
you're here to study you still are
beholden to 263 39a but what we're
saying is with the h2a VISA that you are
not beholden to 263 39a and um and that
creates a discrepancy as far as how
those V how how those processes are
going to be enforced and not only that
it does create some challenges for the
DMV
um
the other thing is when you talk about
records so with these reciprocity
agreements like with the one from Taiwan
we've met with the Taipei economic and
Cultural Center they don't have a um an
embassy or a consulate in Boston but
that is the representative for Taiwan at
least in this area and we talked about
now granted that's with licensing but we
talked about how a license would be
surrendered you know here or in Taipei
we talked about how records would be
updated for driving and infractions both
here and in Taiwan
we talked about what the reciprocity
agreement would really get you and at
the end of the day it would waive the
road test but you'd still have to do the
eye test on the knowledge test so even
with the reciprocity agreement it's not
a uh open green light to basically
operate on a Taiwanese license here in
New Hampshire it doesn't provide for
that this bill actually does though this
bill would allow anybody from any
country around the world to come here to
New Hampshire on their home license
along with if necessary for translation
an international driver's license and to
drive on Interstate 93 89.95 for up to a
year
um and yet we wouldn't know if that
person is suspended in their home
country we wouldn't know if they've
committed negligent homicide with a
motor vehicle in their home country we
won't know we won't know that and um and
so even these reciprocity agreements
aren't just an open invitation to
utilize your current license and come
here there's still a process and it's
still about in the end getting a New
Hampshire license
um
like I said with Jamaica we had a pretty
good idea what the driving standards are
there to get a license and they're very
attractive and I think that that's why
we can work with Jamaica and uh the
consulate there and to try to help the
75 percent of workers that are coming in
but I can't necessarily say that with
every country around the world because
the licensing standards are going to be
different everywhere you go and um and
we want to make sure that if we're going
to allow somebody to drive on the
roadway for a prolonged period of time
through New Hampshire law you want to
make sure on the public safety front
that you know who you're allowing to do
that based on the credential that they
hold and I think that to open that up
globally without having that information
is a public safety issue
I think that covers the testimony that I
have I'll turn it over to Mike Mercier
any additional information Mike yeah I
would just uh want to add in there even
though we may have 75 Jamaican workers
here we're we're when we're opening up
to Jamaicans but there are other uh
Spanish individuals here that could be
from Guatemala Mexico and right now I I
don't believe through the testimony that
we've heard earlier that we we don't
have a reciprocity agreement with
Guatemala we don't have one with Mexico
so through the Free Trade Agreement
they're not getting their license here
on the on the Free Trade Agreement
thank you sir uh questions from the
committee I'll start from the end
representative Jones question please
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
gentlemen for coming
um
this bill is all about the h2a Farm
Workers but there were also other
industries that that bring in
Internationals uh especially the summer
Resort industry and the ski industry in
the winter they bring in people from
Colombia and South
South Africa and many other places and
Jamaica
um
would they well under this bill also
would this pertain to them
no it would that that would be an h2b
Visa that they're under
the questions representative Fox
thank you Mr chair thank you director
um
we've heard testimony that other New
England states have a reciprocity
agreement and uh New Hampshire is the
only one without that do you know how
their
um uh their plan other states plan works
and
and um could we adapt some of those
positive
uh attributes to our plan
so that we can help these
these Farms
thank you representative for the
question I I do know that other states
and I've learned this through the the
work for the rest uh the reciprocal
agreement with Taiwan that other states
around not only New England but around
the country do have these reciprocal
agreements that they set up with
specific countries where they're aware
of what those licensing standards are
and I've seen them I've seen them from
other countries as they relate to Taiwan
um as far as other opportunities beyond
the reciprocal agreement and what's
going on in New England states I'm not
familiar with that offhand but I'd turn
it over to Mike and Ray for anything no
and I'm not familiar with the other
states I just know that with the
reciprocal agreement we can exchange
license for license from their home
country to ours
and that would require a reciprocal
agreement through the consulates in
order to get that program going we could
do some research into that
representative and get that back to you
thank you I'd be very interested to see
how the other states are handling this
or specifically the concerns that you
have and how are they being handled
absolutely we can look into that
yeah thank you it actually takes one of
my questions as well just to see what
they're doing because they may not have
an agreement they could have just passed
a law like this
so any other questions I'll come down
the road representative C
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I was just wondering
if there you mentioned hb2 type Visa are
there other types of visas that might
apply or be similar to something that
would fit in the context of this bill
many type is F1 Visa there's h2b Visa is
um this particular one from what I get
is just to be with agriculture so I
don't know if those other visas would
fall into this category
okay thank you
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman
director marasco good morning good
morning sir how are you today I'm good
it's great to see you um I have some
difficult questions for you I apologize
in advance but I feel that these these
questions have to be asked
so my first and there'll be a couple
follow-ups if you'll indulge with me Mr
chairman please
um first question is can you tell me
what countries have reciprocity
agreements currently with New Hampshire
so I'm told right now sir it's Canada in
France I have not seen the reciprocal
agreement with France I've asked and
nobody can seem to put their hands on it
but I'm told that those are the only two
countries at this time in Taiwan being
in the works but those are the only two
we currently have and do you have any
follow-up please
um
do you remember or do you know when was
the last time a country actually
received a reciprocal agreement from New
Hampshire I don't know
um I'm also aware that uh
the reciprocity agreement with Francis
one of those out there but nobody knows
how it happened
um
how long have you been working at the
reciprocity agreement for Taiwan I mean
I know the answer but I'd like the
committee to hear the answer that's a
fair question
um that was actually started before I
came in
um that was uh agreed upon uh before I
began back in March of of last year
um and so it's still with Department of
Safety legal worked with uh attorney
Karen schlitzer met with the Taipei
economic and cultural Representatives
that was probably about four months ago
maybe five months ago on the priority
list uh with all of the things that go
to Department of Safety legal we don't
have our own DMV attorney we used to I
would certainly love to have that
opportunity again
for clarity's sake though director it's
been years
I it's been I can tell you that um it's
been all of my tenure yeah that it's
still it's still swirling around well I
I'm certain that it's been years okay
um
fair enough I
you can see the line of questioning I'm
I I appreciate the DMV's point of view
uh thank you thank you sir
I think reps of sakes representative
Gorski thank you Mr chairman and thank
you director for taking my question
um from if I can understand you
correctly we're still working on the
reciprocity with Jamaica
how we're not no we haven't even started
it sir I haven't even started no because
uh it was never it was never agreed upon
that that was
um we've never gotten to a point where
everybody's coming to the table and said
that's exactly what we want to do
um it was something after the Senate
hearing where we had a bona fide
representative from the consulate that
was there
um but then this bill in its current
state
passed Senate Transportation so we've
never circled back around on trying to
identify a reciprocity agreement okay
follow-up follow
if it gets started how long did these
typically take to complete it's a great
question so we were just talking about
in the back of the room
um there are so many
complex and different responsibilities
of the DMV and I can tell you that every
position in the DMV roughly 240
employees 208 full-time with a handful
of openings full time right now
um you know everybody's working at a
high level uh oftentimes multitasking
you really really to do this if we're
going to start looking at reciprocity
agreements across the board with other
countries you probably need a full-time
position or at the very least the
part-time position 29 and a half hours a
week where you could have somebody just
focused on that that could work directly
with the OS legal they could check up on
the standards for the country identify a
point of contact identify like we are
with Taiwan okay John wants to go to
Taipei I have to live there for nine
months before I can apply for a
Taiwanese driver's license but before I
go I have to go to the New Hampshire DMV
I have to ask and request for my record
I have to make sure that it's certified
and then at the end of nine months when
I'm in Taipei I can go I can present my
certified record I can also at that time
surrender my New Hampshire driver's
license to the Taiwanese authorities and
there's a mechanism for them to mail it
back to Boston and then to have them
mail it back to the New Hampshire DMV
there's a lot that goes into the
reciprocity agreement it can be done but
quite frankly there's a lot of countries
that would probably be eligible for this
and in order to do that though you've
got to have a position or two that can
focus on it because
it's it's hard to ask employees who are
constantly issuing titles uh helping
people at the counter uh issuing
registrations dealing with financial
responsibility phone calls and all of a
sudden take on This research it's hard
um so I think if we're going to make
this commitment moving forward I've got
to figure out through the next budget a
way to
provide for this layer of employee
support to do this
thank you
represent well before I go to
representative Hill
assuming you had the Manpower would you
need a statute or a bill to create the
reciprocity agreement with Taiwan or is
that something you could do under your
own jurisdiction
you don't have to check on that I think
the um I think the reciprocity
agreements let me check on that and get
you a an answer in writing fair enough
thank you representative Hill
thanks Mr chairman and that took one of
my questions out of the way
um thank you director for taking my
questions I um
I'm
I'm still looking for a solution for
these guys sitting right here
um
it doesn't sound from what I heard from
you that this bill
is that pathway because it sounds to me
from what you were saying you believe
because of the generic nature of this
and and the fact that
um this opens it up to virtually every
country
um that it isn't the correct vehicle for
us to do this
my question is
would it be possible to tailor this to
specifically
um a circumstance rather than
because it sounds like we're only
talking about one country Jamaica in
this case is it possible to tailor this
so that it doesn't
um
sour your feelings of the legislation
um as it relates to other countries
can can we can we work with this
and and satisfy these guys and and the
department
yeah I think you could I think if you if
you made this bill focused on Jamaica
um then you certainly could you could
negate the need for the reciprocity
agreement you could do it through law
the only problem with that not problem
but only consideration with that is you
know now it's it's is it law for every
every time that we want to take a look
at a country that we might want to have
might want to respect their driver's
license based on their licensing
credentials
um the reciprocity agreement
um I I want to say sir I don't think
that it's law on that I think it is an
agreement based on the standards that
you can you do have some flexibility
with that I will get you that and ready
to confirm it
um to make sure I'm right on that but
um in speaking with the OS legal it
sounded like that was a little bit more
flexible so either way representative I
guess to answer your question either way
you could do it through this bill you
could do it through law you can make it
Jamaica focused and you could solve it
that way or we could take a look at the
reciprocity agreement and do that
quick follow-up yeah follow up thank you
um
if it if it was focused if we utilize
this and we focused it strictly on
Jamaicans
um or Jamaica
would it necessarily entail I'm not sure
from this whether
we're dealing with a an issued New
Hampshire license or whether we're
allowing them to drive on their Jamaican
license yeah that's that's just one of
those areas that I think needs to be
this just seems too generic to me I
don't know if that's true from the from
your department
yeah it's a great great distinction that
you make there so the the rest like I
said with the with Taiwan uh the
reciprocal agreement
um is still it's still to
um eventually uh you know you still have
to come to the DMV and test you still
have to go through the eye exam you
still have to do the Knowledge Test
there's still our standards and
Milestones that you have to meet after
the research is done to identify that oh
the licensing standards there are
similar to here
um the nice thing about the reciprocity
agreement is it lays all that out it
lays all of it out after the research is
done and it says this is exactly what
this agreement will allow for it allows
you to not have to take the road test
but these are the things that you still
have to do whereas you'd still have to
do that research if you're going to put
it into the bill
um but I guess you could I guess you
could do it that way as well and make it
more narrow and focused on Jamaica and
identify what those standards are but I
do think the agreement is a better way
to probably address it only because as
looking at the ones that I've seen from
other states on Taiwan it just makes it
Crystal Clear it's more of a memorandum
of understanding and agreement than it
is something that's law and in a in a
bill
um
which is going to be a little bit more I
think you probably have more information
in the build than you probably need
whereas the agreement allows for that
dovetailing of different aspects of how
this is going to work but let's just my
thoughts off the top I'm certainly open
to conversations on this bill and how to
amend it to do what an agreement would
do but I think the agreement probably
would be the way to go
okay any other questions on this side of
the room we are running a half an hour
late so everybody's had a shot at it is
it super critical or is it an answer you
can get on the side at like the closest
hearing and move on okay thank you very
much gentlemen we'll be talking soon on
this with that I apologize for being a
little late I'm going to close the
public hearing
on Senate Bill 187 and turn around and
open up the public hearing within a
minute on 188.
being 136 I'm going to open up the
public hearing on Senate bill 188.
relative to catalytic converters chair
recognizes the prime sponsor Senator
Benton glad to be back
thank you Mr chair and Ladies and
Gentlemen of the committee for the
record I am Senator Donovan Fenton to
represent District 10. I am here to
introduce Senate Bill 188 this bill
places a variety of record-keeping
requirements on catalytic converter and
scrap metal dealers and requires their
cooperation with law enforcement in the
event of a theft so what is a catalytic
converter
um a catalytic converter is part of your
car's exhaust system that converts
harmful engine exhaust pollutants into
something less harmful to the
environment through a chemical reaction
so why are people stealing them they
contain three metals that Aid in the
chemical reaction that makes exhaust
less harmful and those are Platinum
Palladium and rhodium and these prices
of these metals have risen dramatically
as a result one catalytic converter is
worth anywhere from 150 to 1500 and can
be signed off in a sign off of a car in
a matter of minutes
State Farm reported that in just the
first half of 2022 it had received more
than 23 000 catalytic converter theft
claims nationally and New Hampshire is
no dealer no no different we are seeing
dealerships rental cars uh UPS
facilities being hit as well as cars
just parked on the street
this bill would help curb the theft of
catalytic converters by regulating the
purchase of the automobile parts by
scrap metal dealers we're going to
require proof of identification and a
bill of sale or other document
indicating ownership from the sellers
thank you for your time and I'll take
any questions
thank you sir questions from the
committee
representative Hill
good morning Senator thank you very much
good to see you representative
um
would it would it the bill in any way or
do we have any assurances that uh
someone who steals one of these couldn't
just take it to a scrap yard outside of
New Hampshire no I mean we we can't
jurisdict outside of New Hampshire yeah
but but I will say that Most states
around us have passed comprehensive laws
dealing with catalytic converters so the
the the
tactic here is to cut off where they can
sell these catalytic converters so are
they going to steal it and now drive
three or four states over uh
Massachusetts pass a very similar law to
this so hopefully that'll stop them as
well that's the question thanks very
much
for the questions
thank you very much thank you always
good to be back thank you guys
uh chair recognizes it looks like Kyle
sipples from Littleton Auto saver group
in support of the bill looking for five
minutes if you can cut it to less than
that it would be appreciated
we have dealerships in uh one in New
York but mostly Vermont and New
Hampshire
and two things I wanted to address
number one is Vermont passed a similar
law to the one that you're looking at
today and what we found is that our
dealerships in Vermont catalytic convert
converter theft went down roughly 90
percent so the bill was tremendously
successful with one exception
the dealerships we own that are right on
the border of New Hampshire did not see
the reduction that our dealerships
further into Vermont saw so I it was
clear to us where the catalytic
converters were going
um so we know that that if the
surrounding states pass laws
um so Massachusetts Vermont has similar
laws
um they these are bulky items and they
don't like to travel far with these
items because it's pretty obvious what
you're doing
um so I just want to say I can say from
our personal experience with this type
of legislation is it's extremely
effective number two I think one message
that really gets lost here uh is that
roughly 50 percent of the catalytic
converters we've had stolen from our
lots are from customers who have left
their vehicles to be serviced
and the shiny new cars get put on the
front where the police drive by
um but the other you know the service
customers cars tend to be farther back
we uh just this winter we had a plow
truck uh business sole person with one
truck he was out of business for three
months waiting for a catalytic converter
to come in there's so many are being
stolen you've got the supply chain
issues we've had landscapers Carpenters
people that depend on their vehicles it
is not uncommon for them to be out for
two three months and literally not it
you can't rent a plow truck at least not
easily so it's had a tremendous impact
not just on businesses but consumers as
well so with that I'll keep my comments
brief
what about a test pipe but anyway any
questions from the committee
representative sellers thank you Mr
about how many are being taken are
stolen
so roughly it depends on the dealership
but it comes in waves
um but generally somewhere in the 15 to
20 a year and we're up in Littleton so
um I would say averaging 15 to 20 a year
and you're looking at roughly three
thousand dollars to replace these uh
depends on the size of the vehicle
that's anywhere from two to five
thousand dollars and we've been eating
that cost
um
I don't know how long we can but
yeah it has been a problem everywhere um
any other questions from the committee
seeing then thank you very much thank
you very much
uh next up Travis Allen
Enterprise Rent-A-Car in support of the
bill looking for three minutes
good morning chairman Walsh and
committee uh my name is Travis Allen I'm
a risk manager for Enterprise Rent-A-Car
my territory and my current role is uh
the majority of Massachusetts
geographically New Hampshire and Maine
I'm here today in support of SB 188
um we're no stranger to this in being a
victim of this type of illicit activity
as a car rental company we
um you know similarly to delivery
services Postal Services UPS we have a
lot of cars on a lot
you know left unattended uh for for
weekends or overnight and this activity
is um
it's really concerning to us as a
business and it's it's concerning to you
know our employees as Citizens as well
uh for for their personal vehicles
um since the pandemic started the
National Insurance crime Bureau has
reported an increase of 1215 percent of
catalytic converter theft across the U.S
um as Senator Fenton had mentioned it as
you know there's the catalytic
converters have three very valuable
um Metals in their rhodium Palladium and
platinum and the thieves can get into
these cars
uh with a Sawzall and underneath it and
be gone in two to three minutes per car
it's very easy and uh we we for to to
cut this piece of the vehicle off and um
you know we're we're strongly in support
of this
um one thing to let the committee know
uh similar to the previous gentleman
mentioned in Vermont
um
main past legislation similar to this uh
last summer
Massachusetts passed legislation in
January that's similar to what's in
front of the committee today
um in my role as a risk manager we
prior to that legislation in those
States being passed we would see uh in
Maine and New Hampshire our main and New
Hampshire operations
three to five
occurrences on our vehicles of theft of
catalytic converter per month uh in
Maine I believe since in in the nine
months since the legislation passed
we've only seen two and in Massachusetts
uh we've only seen one in the last three
months so it appears to be working
and I would Echo the sentiments that
surrounding states have all enacted
Connecticut Vermont Massachusetts Maine
they've all passed similar legislation
and these Rings my concern would be
would start operating up here where the
offloading of the stolen catalytic
converters would be uh easier because
it's not regulated that we would see
this activity uptick in New Hampshire
um if this uh if this does not pass
thank you sir questions from the
committee
see you then thanks again thank you next
step chair recognizes Wallace tickham
New Hampshire Catalyst we're finding LLC
opposed to the bill
says you're looking for 15 minutes but
if you could help me out it would be
appreciated yes sir
brief
when as Wallace took them I currently am
a managing partner of New England
Catalyst and refining in Manchester New
Hampshire
a lot of this bill a lot of this bill I
think is probably already written into
law
I've been cooperating with police since
I've been in the business I'm 48 years
in the scrap business
and I think I'm well qualified because I
I pretty much can
can sniff out or
be able to identify certain converters
that are stolen so what our what our
what I do when I bike analytic
converters I get I get licenses names
addresses all that everything goes on a
receipt
everybody signs a receipt
comes to photographs the only time I do
that is if I
very very convinced that the converter
could be stolen
and what I do is we'll take the picture
and picture the picture of the
customer's license all that stuff
and it goes what's called leads online
which any Police Department in a state
can can become a part of I guess there's
a fee to it but once they get on leads
online they can see the activity that
we're that we have and the people that
we're targeting is or not targeting but
highlighting is possible thieves
now
I think the big thing that the people uh
I'm going off script here
the big problem is drugs
especially in the city of Manchester and
the police in the Manchester are so
overwhelmed with murders and stabbings
Etc
that I don't believe they really can
take the time
to
you know to follow up on a lot of the
converter I just went to court a week
and a half ago against
one of my customers who had sold excuse
me sold me stolen catalytic awareness he
didn't steal them personally but he sold
them to me
now the record keeping
is not a problem with me
the idea was when he brought him to me I
recognized the converters I informed him
that they were one of the often stolen
converter and they were getting put
aside now my policy has always been
if
I have a little bit of an Inkling
the converters get put away for three
days
if I'm very convinced they get put away
for seven days ten days is a little much
people see this in a legislation and my
doors are going to come off the hinges
so that's why it's only the certain
customers that I feel may have sold me
stolen material the material gets set
aside all by itself
for seven days maximum
I got broken into last year saving
catalytic converters it cost me ten
thousand dollars it hurt but I'm not
crying about it because I do as much as
I can to make sure these guys don't even
come to me
so I had an agreement with the state
police well certain people in the state
police
and a local police
if they had a suspect and they named
that suspect I mean it's not on the
mission of guilt for a guy but if they
name that suspect
he wouldn't be allowed in my door
so I have no problem cooperating with
the police but one of the biggest
problems I have is
photographing everybody
that's gonna that is
that's way that's that's overboard
if I if I got to put up with four or
five people at my door at a time because
it happens often and I got to start
taking pictures of everybody
I mean that interferes with my business
and a lot of these people I already know
so
anyway
one issue that I really have on this
bill
and I've been looking
I'm extensively on this
where you want to make it a law that I
have to pay by check
now from everything I understand checks
debit cards and credit cards are not
considered legal tender
the US dollar currency is considered
legal tender
so how you can force me to pay outside
of tender I don't I really don't
understand I mean you people can do
whatever you want
you know I
I will do what I can to comply but as
far as pushing me on signing or writing
checks
that's going to be way over the way over
it
and
one caveat
Not only was it the pandemic but prices
in 2020 were through the roof
they lasted up until about
August or September of last year the
prices have gone down as much as 50 to
60 percent on these catalytic converters
so even that
I don't know how to put it we call them
crack babies
the people that are on drugs
they they're getting discouraged
because the converters are still not
worth anything all right let's
stick with the with with the bills
anything else sir
no that's it for me thank you very much
does anybody have any questions I did
have one how many how many people in New
Hampshire do that your type of recycling
well I don't even know I wouldn't have
that but I mean there's there's many
well here's the thing because you the
only reason I ask is you mentioned I'm
sure you're running a reputable business
and and some of these would-be thieves
won't go to you but they're going to be
going someplace so I'm just looking to
see how many other businesses do this
type of work and I can find that out
excuse me here's the issue
the state of New Hampshire I love this
state I grew up here
they're very very they've been very very
lenient for the most part from the time
I was a child the state pretty much
stays out of people's business
but the problem with this business is
it's a fair weather business
so when prices go high on anything
everybody's a scrap guy as soon as the
prices collapse you can't find them with
a search warrant these people disappear
so guys like me
I get stuff like this dropped on me
I'm not I'm not opposed to the bill just
certain sectors of the bill
all right so thank you
um
next up and last to speak Dan Bennett
and Hampshire Auto Dealers Association
and support the bill looking for one
minute
oh that only that says three
I thought I wrote 13.
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee it's nice to see you all
again Dan Bennett New Hampshire Auto
Dealers Association as you know we're a
trade Association for the motor vehicle
business in New Hampshire about 500
businesses all over the state
um this uh catalytic converter theft
um plague
um has been impacting car dealers
um as you heard from Mr sipples from the
auto saver group I get about weekly
calls on this issue
um we worked with Senator Fenton on this
bill to create the language and what we
did was we copied the Massachusetts law
almost identically so that folks
wouldn't be not selling a limit in New
Hampshire and just run into the scrap
yard in Revere so we wanted to make sure
that there was continuity we also looked
at the other approaches that were done
in Maine and Vermont which involved
etching or labeling the converters
it's a problem that's uh it's it's not a
great solution because um
any etching can just be removed with a
simple abrasive so choking off the
illegal Marketplace at the point of sale
was the approach to this bill
um I don't want to be too repetitive
um and get into medals or anything like
that another data point for you all is
Carfax released a study that said there
were 153 000 catalytic converter thefts
in 2022 from Vehicles reported through
Carfax
um
the bill doesn't prevent the sale of of
legal
um catalytic converter sales
um but what it does is it aims to to
create
um and I heard from the previous speaker
with the opposition all it does I heard
record keeping is not a problem all this
is is a record-keeping bill
so it allows for legal sales through a
simple record-keeping process in the
Senate there were amendments made that
appeased law enforcement uh that dealt
with the the data Privacy Act uh it
appeases State Police as far as who has
jurisdiction over enforcement there was
also an amendment made that would help
out the auto and truck recyclers who do
these in in massive volumes because they
take in whole cars and then part them
out so there was an amendment that
appeased them as well so
um there is federal action on the bill
on this issue but um who knows how long
that could take we've been hearing about
it for three years with the federal
Parts act that involves both
record-keeping enhanced penalties but
also an etching program the etching
program would start at the manufacturer
when the vehicle is built
um however we uh the average age of a
vehicle in the in the states is 12 years
so by the time that actually made it out
into the marketplace it would be years
and years away when this would have an
impact
so multiple States had to just go ahead
and take their own action
um and that's what the proposal that you
have um in front of you now and we hope
that you uh Hope to support the bill and
and help us kind of
um like as mentioned choke off this
illegal Marketplace
so thanks and I'll take any questions if
there are any thank you any questions
from the committee representative
sellers thank you Mr so I just want to
make sure that this this bill if as it
is right now if I go in and sell a
catalytic converter to a scrap yard
they're gonna take my picture and pay me
by check is that correct
they're not going to take your picture
they're going to take a picture of the
catalyst converter they're also going to
take a photocopy of your driver's
license
and again we did hear the previous
speaker too we won't be executing this
today so we'll look into all the angles
of this seeing none thank you very much
thank you um I have nobody else signed
up to speak I'm going to close the
public hearing on Senate bill 188. now
what to do with the next one it is
11 56 I was afraid this might happen but
we were looking pretty good for a while
committee's Choice uh we could take a
just a couple of minute break I need one
and push through into lunch or I can
open up the public hearing and
reschedule it for after lunch how do you
all feel
keep going keep going okay
all right that's what I wanted to hear
anybody opposed to five minutes
no
okay
so what I'm going to do I'm going to
open up the public hearing on a Senate
Bill 256 and I'm going to recess the
public hearing on Senate Bill 256 until
1205.
all right being 1205 on the money I'm
gonna open up the
public hearing on Senate bill 256.
establishing a safety program for off
Highway recreational vehicles I see it's
a daily fernet uh representing Senate
award the prime sponsor
to introduce the bill good afternoon
good afternoon chairman Walsh and
members of the committee my name is
Daley frenette I am the Senate majority
caucus director I'm here to introduce
Senate Bill 256 FN which would establish
both a lifetime and temporary safety
program certificate requirements for off
Highway recreational vehicles on behalf
of Senator Ward
Senator Ward was asked to introduce this
bill by the New Hampshire off highway
vehicle association which represents oh
RV clubs throughout the state who have
been working on trying to pass similar
legislation for three years
this legislation is a modified version
of previous attempts and was worked on
by stakeholders which include the
department of fish and game New
Hampshire Auto Dealers Association and
the ohrv industry
this this bill would create a phased in
approach for acquiring ohrv Riders born
after January 1st 1978 to take either a
lifetime permanent training a course or
a temporary training course which would
be valid for one calendar year
it would grandfather in anyone born
after 1978 and anyone who has already
completed an improved Fish and Game
training course either in New Hampshire
or another state
this year's version of the bill only
deals with ohrvs and not snowmobiles
both Industries are rapidly growing and
helping our state's outdoor recreation
economy but this bill focus on focuses
on AOH RVs which rely more heavily on
private land and especially the use of
public roads
training courses also already educate
users on both ohrv and snowmobiles so it
would have a positive impact on both
user groups
members of our local oh RV clubs often
are already knowledgeable and respectful
of their communities this bill aims to
try and reduce the number of Bad actors
and accidents by having young
out-of-state Riders especially renters
learn the rules on safety and to be
better educated to respect our
communities and private landowners which
are vital to preserve the existing trail
system and valuable economic impacts
ohrvs provide the tourism and outdoor
recreation industries of our state
there are several amendments adopted in
the Senate to improve this bill the
first amended the bill to make it clear
the temporary certificate would be valid
only for one calendar year and that
certificate would be ready by July 1st
of 2024. originally uh they accompli
they contemplated starting the temporary
certificate in 2025 to give time for
rulemaking but the rental Community has
asked for it to be done by July 1st of
2024 to ensure renters born after 1998
we'll also have to have access to
Temporary option next season
the other change makes it absolutely
clear a safety course will not be
required for farming employees working
on someone else's land stakeholders
believe the bill had already uh would
exempt this but the the language ensures
that this will not uh there will not be
any confusion
Senator Ward asks for your support for
the passage of Senate Bill 256 to help
ensure Riders are better equipped to
operate their vehicles and help preserve
safety on our thriving public and
private trail system in the state thank
you for the opportunity to speak today I
will defer any questions to the
stakeholders and fish and game thank you
thank you very much
next up chair recognizes Mike Willette
he's been here for a while representing
metallak ATV Club I hope I'm saying that
correctly in support of the bill
thank you very much uh chairman and the
committee members
I'm here to support the bill and I'm
here today to talk about the club's
point of view my name is Mike Willette I
live in Colebrook I'm a representative
from Co-op District three I'm also the
trail administrator for metallic ATV
Club where the largest at Club in the
state with over a thousand members and
over 120 miles of trails
over the last 15 years in the North
Country we've lost about 5 000
manufacturing jobs so our economy has
changed from a manufacturing logging
economy to a tourist-based economy
so ohrv is a big part of our economy
there are over a thousand let me
rephrase that there's over between 12
and 1300 miles of trails in the state of
New Hampshire oh RV trails with a
thousand of them being in the North
Country alone
it's got such an economic impact and I'm
going to quote you some numbers I'm not
saying they're 100 correct but
my last reading that's what they were
skiing in the state of New Hampshire
brings about 550 million dollars of
economic impact into the state
snowmobiling is around 500 million and
the last study I saw with the ohribs
it's 440 million dollars of economic
impact in the state of New Hampshire
annually so it's very important part of
our North Country economy
the
I won't go through the technical part of
the bill but this mandatory safety
course is very similar to the very
successful snowmobile course that's been
going on for decades in state of New
Hampshire
the main problems we have with safety
in both Sports usually is because
inexperience and speed
and this bill will help Target the
inexperienced Riders and also
educate the aggressive young adults out
there writing that need some education
to be respectful
there are some challenges right now that
ohrv is currently face
and one of the biggest problems is
landowners and cultivating cooperating
landowners to open their land and also
to allow us to have trails
a writer can come up into the North
country and write 100 miles
very easily never see a house never see
a camp
most riders that come in that area that
ride those kind of distances think the
land is public it's not
um
more than in the North Country over 90
percent of the land is privately owned
the
some of the problems we have with riders
is uh
leaving trash riding off Trail creating
ruts when it's wet not a following or
obeying science and excessive noise and
dust and what I think this bill can
accomplish
it's just a few things that are very
very important it can reduce accidents
and and injuries just through education
it's going to educate writers how to
respect the landowners and understand
the crucial role they play in the sport
without Cooperative landowners we have
no sport
it's it's that important
it's also going to educate writers how
the clubs fit into this program
I know our club in the last two years
rerouting a trail we spent 370 thousand
dollars building a trail a single Trail
to avoid some Road sections get away
from houses and a piece some landowners
the club's share of that 370 000 was
over two hundred thousand dollars
the state share was around 170 000.
so the clubs have a very important part
in the sport most
riders that come up don't realize how
important that part is
so it's important for them to learn
the importance and
of the landowners and how crucial they
are
to understand how the clubs fit in
cultivating Trails building trails and
retaining landowners
the uh a lot of writers do not
understand that the bureau Trails has a
big part in this through their Grant aid
program and helping the sport
and a lot do not understand the roles of
Fish and Game
and and how they fit in this with their
registrations event permits and law
enforcement
in my opinion there's no downside to
this bill there's a small inconvenience
to varieters to take their safety course
but it'll improve the sport and and help
protect it I hope that you will support
this bill
thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee representative C
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question on page two of the
bill they talk about uh operator Danny's
birth and certificate retired or those
honored before or on or after dates it
doesn't say so it
as I read it it means only if you were
born on that particular January 1st that
it applies I'll I'll let Lieutenant
Eastman uh stand at the technical part
of it but from what I understand it was
for for people who were born a certain
date in 1978 or later
if you're born pre-1978 you will not
have to be part of the safety course
and I think that's to Target the young
aggressive drivers
any further questions and
all set
okay
um I just want one one statement for me
I can do that on the chair did you say
it's uh the metallic ATV Club yes and I
apologize for my pronunciation but so
everybody knows in my own defense it's
spelled
m-e-t-a-l-l-a-k so thank you for that
and for your information metallic was
the last Native American living in that
area cut it out thank you very much for
that and our Trails go by his graveside
no thank you
um cheer next up recognizes
Rich Parsons representing the Hampshire
off road highway vehicle association
Nova
um in support of the bill
good afternoon chairman Walsh and
members of the committee my name for the
record is Rich Parsons I work at ryp
Granite strategies here in Concord and I
represent the New Hampshire off highway
vehicle association we represent 25
ohvere clubs throughout the state and I
think it was alluded to earlier that
we've been working on something for
several years to try and get something
to work I know the first version was
based primarily on the boater safety
certificate program which has been very
successful but this takes a bit of a
different approach it's a little bit of
a hybrid for example Vermont has a born
after date that you're required to get
it so this takes a phased in approach
sort of like the boater safety program
but also a born after date
and to answer your question
representative in on page two line 15 it
does say it says no person born after so
I think it um should be assumed that
those dates are if you're born after
that date if you're born on January 1st
itself that obviously would be a little
confusing for you
um
so I but I think it's supposed to be if
you're born after those days
um so some information we have
in terms of the folks that this would
impact in 2024 under 25 based on 20 22
registrations it'd be roughly
six and a half percent of all Riders
were under the age of 25 that would have
to complete or have something done in
2024 I think it was 996 residents in
1008 non-residents from there the year
after would be 16 and a half percent of
users and 36 to 45 which would be in
2026 is about 19 and a half percent of
users I mean the over 46 plus crowd it
makes up 57.7 percent of users so the
majority of users wouldn't be impacted
by this and I think it's also important
to note that if you have already taken
a course you can use that as your
lifetime certificate whether in the
state of New Hampshire or one recognized
by fish and game so there should be a
good amount of people especially those
under the age of 25. most of them likely
took when they if they started when they
were youth they likely took our safety
training program already and fish and
game has records on on all those folks
that took it
um so it's been mentioned already so
I'll just quickly just say
um you know our association supports
this legislation you know especially
with our use in Reliance on private
lands we think
Riders especially renters could benefit
from additional etiquette to ride on
these trails that these landowners are
nice enough to allow us to use and also
for when they're riding on roads because
roads are much different some of these
vehicles the tire pressure
makes it unique in that they need to
understand that it's going to ride
differently when it's on a road so the
goal is to reduce accidents you know
increase etiquette for folks to help
make sure that we can continue to have a
thriving economy from these vehicles in
the North country and other parts of the
state
so with that I'll take any questions
thank you very much I just got one to
start off excuse me I don't disagree
with representative C and I agree with
you that I think it's assumed that after
is what what's being intended you've
been working on the language on this
because can you find a different way to
maybe clarify that because I agree with
them yes you can't really pass something
that we assume is
what we want it's kind of going to be
spelled a little clearer than that so
that would be appreciated any other
questions from the committee
representative Jones
thank you Mr chairman and thank you sir
for being here
um
under this category does
are we including two-wheel three-wheel
and four-wheel
anyone that is required to have yeah an
or HRV registration that that gets one
on the state so it's trail bikes two
bikes two wheels three wheels four
wheels yeah utvs all those are included
and can I just ask you what is a gator
uh
Captain Eastman I think can probably
answer that in a little more detail I've
never ridden on a Gator myself it's a
it's a name brand oh okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
representative sellers uh thank you Mr
chair and to me being here and I might
not have read it yet and my apologies
but
how how much does this training course
gonna cost an individual and how many
hours or how much time they have to put
into it
yeah so the in-person training courses
are free that you can sign up for one of
the ones offered by a fish and game or
an approved training course
um if you are doing the temporary
certificate that is contemplated in the
bill that'll be offered
um through an approved program at a
location so I believe that is also free
the online course that is offered now I
think is 35 if you want to take an
online course in terms of the time I
think it's a temporary
and I'll let Captain Eastman correct me
if I'm wrong here would be
you know 30 minutes to an hour probably
closer to an hour
whereas the lifetime certificate is like
a five to six hour intensive class in
person class
what are the questions
seeing none you're off the hook
thank you very much
next up share recognizes Captain Eastman
from representing New Hampshire fishing
game law enforcement in support of the
building
welcome sir
good morning
chair Walsh and the committee as I said
my name is Michael Eastman I'm a captain
of the Hampton fish and game department
law enforcement Division I am in the
coordinator of actually the ohrv
coordinator in charge of safety
education and enforcement we uh my
commission Fishing Game Commission
supported this bill I'm really here to
speak about the safety component of this
and the capability of my agency to
handle
um this uh this course
as uh Mr Parsons said we do have a we we
have had for a very long time a live
course
which has a minimum of five and a half
hours of training it's generally a day I
have Regional coordinators and
volunteers that that put those on across
the state and they can be signed up for
online through our website we also have
through calcamy our online platform
which has been around
for
at least five years I take that back at
least six to eight years I'm not 100
sure one that was incepted but that uh
that is a
34.95 course
um and that is none of that a fee comes
back to my agency that is for calcamy to
maintain that platform
so that was is out there it can be done
I've I've spoken with folks that uh did
it in the amount of time to drive from
Rhode Island to the state to actually uh
to go and and use
um the uh the ohrv trails in our state
as far as the uh and that can be done at
any time I re the last I reviewed it
um was last year and uh just looking at
it took me about about three hours to
complete that and that would be your
your course for
um or you'll get your card in the mail
from calcamy and be good for it's a
lifetime card as far as the um
the temporary course which was something
that the um the rental dealers looked
for us to to put in
um that uh we would need to work with
calcium to get that online so that they
could um so that a person could just go
online and and and take that course and
be ready for uh and be ready to to come
and and what it would really be designed
for is that if I were coming to the
North country or anywhere in the state
where I was going to rent a an ohrv that
I would be able to do that prior to
coming to the state or I could do it at
the rental agent and we would look in my
mind about an hour course so
um and get them out there and that would
be heavy on etiquette
um and and laws and and rules of the
road that type of thing
thank you sir questions from the
committee
wow
seeing none I don't even have one myself
seeing uh thank you very much thank you
that is the last person I have signed up
to speak on Senate bill 256. so I'll
close the public hearing
so we weren't too too bad yeah 25
minutes
uh the only other thing I want to
mention and I don't need answers today I
do have a list for anybody that would
like to grab one at this point of the
retained bills that we do have retain
house bills once we do exact these uh
historically the speaker will let us
start working on anything we have
retained once we're caught up with our
work here so please help yourself to
grabbing one of these
and take a look
and we have other handouts as well and
see if there's any of these committees
or what we're going to create
subcommittees any of these topics you'd
be interested in helping with working on
over the summer months send them to
default
so that being said
um I'll reach out or actually when I do
do it better I know I've got a couple
issues with people going on uh work and
vacation
we do have times so reach out to me if
you've got a particular day you can't
make it to Executives we'll leave it at
that
okay
um if I don't hear from anybody then
I'll just pick it myself but I'll try to
make it so that we can all be here and
we don't have to rely on on replacements
no no
yeah no no we got we got plenty we've
got till June 1st yeah I don't want to
wait that long yeah
but I know we've got a couple a couple
of the things we looked at today there
might be a few amendments to uh coming
so again it won't be next week and if
there's a particular day outside of next
week that doesn't work for you let me
know
I'm gonna stick with Tuesdays yep and
what are the questions
CNN thanks very much and uh we'll see
you soon
foreign